now I'm known as the tooth fairy they
love productions Chris is not a dentist
he's a special effects artist who crafts
custom choppers so stars can really sink
their teeth into a roll whoever you met
Robert De Niro go straight take
Blanchette Helena bonham-carter
for Merrill he made her witchy Thor into
the woods gave her Margaret Thatcher's
protruding teeth for the Iron Lady and
created the false as she wears on big
little eyes I find little people to be
untrustworthy Merrill normally has up to
about three sets such that remain in two
spares when we did Rami Malek in
Bohemian Rhapsody we made 20 sets
I got this phone call top-secret phone
call sign your life away on NDA's and
that's my cassette Freddie teeth so we
made them a year before he was even
greenlit I saved those and not only did
I save them I cast them in gold and that
is not something I would normally do but
I thought what is the most audacious
ostentatious thing that Freddie would do
Chris has also worked his magical
wizardry at Hogwarts we did someone
harry potter where some of the kids were
losing teeth so we had to replace the
teeth so they turn the shot around and
then literally an hour later who they
turn the cameras where we go
he created Javier Bardem villainous look
for Skyfall he made all the White
Walkers chompers at Game of Thrones and
he crafted Madonna's overbite for Evita
[Music]
[Applause]
to start the stars meet with Chris for a
half an hour for fitting then it takes
this company fangs that that's about two
weeks to deliver the goods why do you
think celebrities keep coming back here
for their teeth trust quality and I
suppose they like me I might not say
Merrill for five years and she'll walk
in it's a hug gonna kiss and it's and
she remembers your name and it's that's
mental
those just bizarre
[Music]
[Applause]